[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans six ans
par les sports dernière émission de
l'année 2018 sur le sport local pour
refermer cette année en beauté j'ai
convié autour de cette table les
meilleurs chroniqueurs du département et
ils sont survoltés comme jamais
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite il est comme le fair noël
il rend heureux tout l'été spectateurs
quand il revient sur cette émission le
seul l'unique le capitaine igen
dujarrier du coq de vélizy 78 et encore
avec nous aujourd'hui
pendant une heure orbital royal quand
allez-vous très très bien la rive de
noël qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
on pas grand chose pas grand chose non
pour moi c'est déjà noël ce sont des
jours comme les autres d'accord ça sera
un peu triste du coup cette émision
jamais triste mais voilà vrai nom
j'apporte peu d'importance à vos fêtes
de fin d'année c'est noté en tout cas on
passe de l'autre côté musique c'est
notre cadeau de noël avant l'heure
elle est aussi douce qu'un flocon de
neige qui tombe sur la joue en plein
hiver elle adore les moments romantiques
au point du feu avec une boisson chaude
et un film de noël notre ambassadrice de
charme
hélène de la grange est avec nous est de
retour oui oui mais oui vous m'avez
manqué là donc je suis content que je
reviens ce qui se passe là dernière
parfois j'ai des occupations et je ne
peux pas être là donc voilà votre
priorité
mais parfois ces pannes ou les doubles
et je peux pas repasser de l'autre côté
musique
à long terme il est notre étoile de noël
le all star de cette équipe ce passionné
a de basket licencie au chesnay
versailles revient dans cette émission
avec des analyses sportives dans sa
hotte mesdames et messieurs ladies and
gentleman
quant à jacques bascou est avec nous
j'aime quand on lie quand allez vous
préviens femelle donc vous aussi vous
êtes de retour dans cette émission où
vous étiez en habitué il ya quelques
mois c'est vrai plaisir chez l'autre
pour cette dernière de l'année donc noël
vous il ya beaucoup de travail pour
préparer l'année prochaine d'accord donc
travail avant tout en termine à ma
gauche musique noël et sa période
préférée il arrive en plateau avec des
analyses sportives et quelques blagues
dans sa hotte et on est toujours ravi de
l'avoir avec nous la légende le mythe
coach genlis nous fait l'honneur de
venir sur cette émission nouvelle fois
quand allez-vous pleine forme plate
forme est toujours plein de fond je
voulais être certaine comme elle est là
mais j'ai hésité c'était compliqué mais
il a échangé notamment cazaux maison en
fin d'émission
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission j'aimerais qu'on revienne
rapidement sur la route du rhum le
skipper versailles et de comme un seul
homme
éric bellion est enfin arrivé en
guadeloupe il a terminé sa route du rhum
ce samedi 8 décembre sont en 34 jours et
10 heures
le sportif est arrivé 10e concurrents de
sa catégorie mais la ligne d'arrivée de
la compétition étaient officiellement
fermés depuis le 7 décembre
il ne sera donc pas à classer sur cette
course il enregistré cette vidéo juste
avant son arrivée
on arrive demain bon c'était un pari un
peu fou mais
voilà c'était notre défi et puis je me
dis que tout ça c'est finalement très
peu d'importance
qui compte c'est en boucle tous les deux
cette aventure qu'on ait réussi à passer
des messages à faire en sorte que plein
de gens se sentent concernés aient envie
de réfléchir avec nous et qu'on va finir
la course on va faire le camp de la
guadeloupe on va faire tout le trajet
jusqu'au bout tout le parcours
pour respecter
ce mythe extraordinaire qu'est la route
du rhum il ya du jarrier qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
d'ailleurs je dis gros raté ouais gros
raté je veux bien qu'on parte en disant
je vais prendre mon temps pour faire la
compet etc mais
se trouve que c'est dommage d'arriver
hors délai il aurait pu prendre son
temps tout en respectant le temps qui
est imparti pour pouvoir réaliser la
compétition était pas loin il a été un
jour près oui mais justement c'est ça
c'est il n'est pas loin il est un jour
près eh bien il aurait peut-être pu
hélas je ne ratais pu faire le faire en
sorte d'arriver d'arriver dans les dents
dans le timing est là et parce que
surtout que c'était vraiment la
philosophie de se dire je prends mon
temps je suis tranquille je le fais à la
cool je vais son nom l'autre je médite
avec je milite avec moi même d'ailleurs
ils étaient deux lui et son double
puisque nous étions là il me faisait cas
mais il a apparemment il ay là il a pris
son plaisir
ouais je trouve je trouve que c'est
dommage de rater à un jour le fait de
rentrer dans les délais et je me dis là
petit raté un petit raté de cobb manière
hélène qu'est-ce que vous en pensez mais
je rejoins ce que dit yann pressé a si
peu de temps du délai imparti c'est
dommage c'est il aurait mieux valu
quitte à prendre son temps qu'il arrive
vraiment vraiment hors délai et qu'ils
se fassent entre guillemets une
promenade mais là c'est vraiment dommage
a si peu de temps surtout que je ne sais
pas si tout le monde a terminé la course
mais tout le monde n'a pas terminé la
course en forcément mais oui mais il a
quand même la chance de terminer la
course dont il aurait peut-être pu voilà
terminé
n'a pas pu rapide est arrivé main dans
les délais corneille
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord je plus
d'accord avec ce qu'il a dit le plus
important c'est qu'ils âge
voilà le message qu'ils puissent arriver
jusqu'au bout quoi qu'il arrive
et peut-être que au niveau communication
il disait qu'il allait prendre son temps
mais que lui dans la tête dans sa tête
d'y penser quand même arrivants antoine
a donc finalement les aléas ont fait qu'
il arrivé hors délai mais le plus
important c'est ce qu'ils font sa
défense il a eu il ya eu quand même une
petite tempête au début de course et il
a dû on va dire et c'est en même secteur
le secteur de la bretagne pendant
quelques jours du coup il aurait pu
malgré tout cas l arrivée dans les temps
là je pense qu'ils voulaient c'était
avant sans forcément jouer la première
place où les premières places et que
finalement les aléas ont fait que bas en
prenant son temps il est arrivé hors
délai mais le plus important c'est qu'il
a tenue sa philosophie tout le long et
qu'il a pu méditer sur le genre alors
vous l'aviez un petit peu taquiné lors
de la dernière émission non non non non
non pas du tout pas du tout sinon là il
assez bon on atterrira il est clair il
est arrivé ouais c'est bon ils sont
descendus du nuage là il est pas tout
seul d'ailleurs il le dit lui même
bon et je pense qu'il a bien bien
méditer trop méditation tu la méditation
la gare bon il termine cette course à
nolito ministère mais il vaut mieux
parce que c'est le but quand même
attendre calmement tout sur un bateau
pour faire une course telle que la
course du rhum c'est pour la finir il le
dit lui-même d'ailleurs mais bon là il a
bien réfléchi cela il doit recommencer
ou pas sur ce même angle alors non moi
je tendais l'antre à banon allait aller
plus vite
franchement il faudrait prendre le
contre-pied la prochaine fois fo oui
pour montrer que je peux je suis on a eu
on a eu quand même le débat l'émission
est juste avant c'est quand même une
compétition donc une compétition qui dit
compétition pour respecter la
compétition qu'à la réflexion c'est bien
mais la compétition alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de handball avec le match amical
qui a opposé des jeunes divinement
professionnel du paris 92
nous ferons a également un coup de
projecteur sur le marathonien sidy
diallo qui a couru quinze marathon pieds
nus en 14 semaines
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler de football et de la coupe de
france du football et le 8e tour de la
coupe de france versailles qui évolue en
nationale 3 a failli réaliser le plus
bel exploit de son histoire ce samedi 8
décembre
les hommes de la cité royale se sont
inclinés 4 à 2 face au racing club de
lens un club de ligue 2 mais ils ont
réussi à accrocher les lensois à la mi
temps le score était à ce moment là de
deux partout on écoute les réactions à
la fin du match malgré tout irait
défaite dont l'indicé est parce qu on
abordait ce match là pour par le
remporter
on n'a pas remporté ce match mais je
tiens à saluer le courage l'abnégation
et le coeur que mes joueurs ont mis sur
ce match au fil du match et cette
seconde mi temps on a on a pris un but
assez vite mais on a on a baissé
physiquement et c'est là où c'était plus
dur pour nous avec l'élimination de
versets les yvelinois ne compte plus
aucun représentant en coupe de france
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour vivre
de nouvelles émotions et il aurait pu
faire mieux ou pas que ce 4 à 2 à votre
avis enjoy il aurait certes où il aurait
surtout pu faire mieux s'il n'avait pas
rencontré lens voilà c'est ça qu'on va
convaincre on va dire voilà c'est quand
même dommage de tomber sur un sur un
club de ligue 2 à cette période mais
mais bon on a rarement des clubs qui y
passent les fêtes en coupe de france
dans les yvelines donc donc c'est déjà
c'est déjà très bien c'était des
derniers représentants et c'est aussi un
honneur de sortir de sortir face à une
tasse une face à une équipe de limites
puisque puisqu'avec 200 dt professionnel
à bon après sur le match en lui-même
ils ont donné le maximum mais ils ont
explosé en plein vol dans la deuxième mi
temps ont ils ont ils ont quatre à deux
pas non plus ridicules alors parce
qu'ils ont été capables d'en mettre deux
mais ils en ont pris 2,2 et physiquement
il était aisé terrain c'est reims et
dans la deuxième mi-temps voila mail en
mail
je trouve que c'est un score plutôt
honorable et 2d à la mi temps quand
il y est je pense que c'est très bien
ensuite perdre 4 à gauche je pense que
physiquement exemple pêcher un peu
néanmoins on a déjà vu des matchs avec
des équipes de même niveau se prendre
des 5 à 1 ou 2 6 1 donc 4 à 2 pour moi
c'est pour le foot c'est pas quelque
chose de ridicule
c'est encourageant hélène ce 4 à 2 pour
versailles vraiment pas grand chose tu
pas grand argument d'accord j'avoue
fondre l'écart est pas est pas énorme
après on peut toujours mieux faire c'est
sur la question sur ce thème ce match
était-il une bonne publicité pour le
football yvelinois oui ou non
oui non c'est pas votre truc le football
il à ce sujet là ouais j'espère comme sa
moitié moitié
jean vous a pas entendu ce fut donc une
bonne publicité pour vous et forcément
forcément déjà on connaît la magie de la
coupe de france de football on sait qu'
il n'y a pas de grosse équipe et pas de
petites équipes puisque tous les ans il
ya ce qu'on appelle le petit poucet qui
vient de se glisser dans un des grands
du football français donc on connaît
cette magie donc effectivement comme de
la diane c'est une équipe qui aime lance
de la professionnelle de la ligue ligue
2 troyes 2e division donc forcément club
historique également et club historique
ça c'est sûr on les connaît quand même
sans faire de publicité au sein et en
sang et or qui jouent en bleu qui jouait
on a vu en a vu les images ou un bleu un
bleu --pour pas sur le publicité aux
techniciens de la télévision ici mais
sinon lens et à une grosse équipe c'est
une grosse pub pour pour le département
et le club de versailles je pense que
les joueurs se frotter à ce qui se passe
qui se fait de mieux mais c'est quand
même le monde professionnel c'était un
rêve tout joueur de foot donc c'est que
du positif pour eux plus le score aurait
pas non plus
catastrophique il ya toujours l'amertume
parce que encore une fois je dis c'est
toujours la magie on a toujours l'espoir
que ça peut passer
hees a pu passer le côté physique le
côté entraînement
d'un côté à des professionnels font que
ça de l'autre il ya les gens ils ont
leur boulot et c'est plus un loisir que
un travail donc il n'y a rien à dire
mais c'est que du plus et c'est parfait
le match était retransmis chez nos
confrères d'eurosport
est ce que ça sera un plus également
pour pour le club
corneille oui bien sûr c'est la preuve
on en parle là on montre le match et aux
proches pensent que versailles n'est pas
la passe souvent et le match diffusé sur
eurosport
et s'il n'y avait pas eu ce tour de la
coupe de france il a passé la première
fois pour le club de versailles
enfin retombée financière fortis votera
oui et non c'est une très bonne
publicité
j'espère que ça se reproduira jan cette
retransmission sur eurosport
bah ouais génial vous découvrez coup de
projecteur et donc du coup c'est ce que
je disais un petit peu tout à l'heure
c'est
l' avantage de pouvoir dommage de
rencontrer un club de ligue 2 mais il
vaut mieux sortir en ayant plus voilà
passé sur eurosport le monde qui avait
dans les tribunes et l'ambiance en mêlée
alors ça dans les voilà c'est pas tous
les week-ends comme ça donc ça que pour
les joueurs c'est quand même c'est quand
même quelque chose je garde un très
grand souvenir d'une intervention au
vélodrome devant 2500 personnes c'est
c'est un réel plaisir
donc on ne pratique plus le sport dans
la même dans les mêmes conditions et
donc là ben voilà c'est clair que c'est
dommage de sortir face une ni deux mais
s'il n'avait pas rencontré ni deux il
n'aurait pas eu cette expérience qu'ils
ont pu qu'ils ont pu vivre
et quand on est sportif amateur club
amateur et qui qu'on veut faire contre
s'inscrit sur la coupe de france
l'objectif c'est ça c'est de se dire on
espère rencontrer un gros d'un gros du
du championnat donc voilà pour eux c'est
mission accomplie à tous les niveaux et
en plus ils n'ont pas été ridicules donc
donc c'est parfait
on pensait que ça peut aider le club à
attirer hélène de futurs jour dans le
futur mais toute façon c'est ce qu'on
disait le fait de scouts de côtoyer des
clubs plus gros d'avoir de la visibilité
comme ça forcément que pour le club pour
la région et puis vint pour les
adhérents ja il ya une motivation qui
qui va être qu'il va se créer c'est
toujours des choses bonnes à prendre de
la communication comme ça quel que soit
le résultat le résultat n'est pas
forcément mauvais il est en dessous du
club d'en face mais en même temps c'est
assez logique vu le
la différence de niveau il ya charles
itandje le gardien qui a rejoint
versailles cet été ce que vous pensez
que d'autres professionnels sur sur le
déclin on peut le dire un charles
itandje 36 ans pourrait rejoindre
versailles le conte se disant peut-être
qu'on pourrait aller loin en coupe de
france
forcément ils ont l avantage sur les
autres clubs du même niveau c'est que
eux ont eu la chance de rencontrer une
équipe professionnelle et qui a été
retransmise sur eurosport pour ne pas
les citer
donc forcément c'est une publicité pour
le club et ils ont un coup d'avancé sur
sur leur équipe du même niveau et ça
peut effectivement ça peut faire sourire
certains et eddy certains jeux attirer
certains joueurs en dise ah ben tiens ça
a pas l'air mal il me semble bien ce
club je vais aller jeter un coup d'oeil
finalement leur jeu lors je me plais
puisqu'on a la possibilité de les voir
jouer c'est un plus par rapport à notre
club du même niveau il faut se déplacer
au stade pour aller voir là ont ils sont
passés à la télévision
donc pour eux c'est une belle publicité
effectivement pourquoi pas ça peut
attirer des clubs comme le gardien de
but qui sont un déclin après le football
on passe au rugby dans le championnat
honneur les rugbymans de chevreuse se
sont imposés dans la douleur le 9
décembre contre le voisin à leurs
voisins du sky rugby dans un match
électrique le score de ce derby 32 à 24
on écoute les réactions au micro de tv
60 vite quand même la fierté parce que
on savait que ça va être compliqué c'est
une équipe qui joue le haut de tableau
et malgré tout les a tenus on les a
tenues avec nos armes avec le jeu et la
solidarité après dommage ça nous ça nous
aurait pas mais on va continuer à
travailler avait retourné
on était optimiste on a gagné mais son
manque les deux
sans manquer de respect aux sky je pense
que c'est normal qu'on gagne largement
est par contre
voilà qui n'est pas le bonus ça c'est
pas normal par contre ont une petite
réaction gens par rapport à ses discours
d'après match je le découvre là bas je
suis entraîneur de rugby une de fait je
pense qu'il ne vaut principale qualité
celui dit et là je suis pas sûr qu'ils
avaient face aux preuves non c'est dans
cet entraîneur on parle pas comme ça
c'est pas possible c'est impossible
surtout 32 à 24
oser dire je manque pas de respect au
club adverse mais finalement c'est tout
à fait normal
ils ont rien à voir et puis ce qui me
gêne c'est qu'on n'ait pas pris le bonus
aux femmes et c'est j'espère qui sait où
ça si oui ça me choque énormément et
j'ai vu je le connais bien
j'espère qu'il a analysé son interview
et qui a pas que ça parce que ou alors
ou alors c'est un montage de votre part
ça il n'y a aucun malheureusement mais
je trouve ça fait c'est choquant voilà
le mot c'est choquant parce que c'est un
manque de respect total pour
l'adversaire
et pour pour le monde du rugby
l'humilité sincère et la roue tourne
donc il faut pas qu'ils qui les oublie
tous ces gens c'est c'est pas bien j'ai
j'aime pas vous dire quelque chose
yann et j'ai rien à la roue tourne va
tourner ouais comme disait notre grand
philosophe arriver le message est passé
je vous propose maintenant de regarder
plus en détail les essais de chevreuse
une stratis et stratégie je vais y
arriver basé sur leurs avants à chaque
touche dans les 22 mètres les
entraîneurs faisait rentrer deux joueurs
puissants qui permettait de construire
des môles et de progresser rapidement
dans l'en-but les avants saint
quentinois moins puissants vous pouvez
être que reculer face aux chevreaux d'un
ils ont donc gagné avec leur puissance
sans réelle construction dans le jeu la
question sur ce thème faut-il toujours
gagné avec la manière
oui ou non non non c'est unanime
corneille si on parle de gagner des n'y
a pas de signification c'est gagné par
contre si on parle d'avoir un beau jeu
oui on peut certainement décliné avoir
un jeu qui a plus de gueule etc
mais si on parle de gagner ben y'a pas
de manière de gagner c'est avoir un
point de plus que l'adversaire
n vous êtes attaché d'accord peu importe
la manière seule victoire contre voilà
après c'est ça sera ça lance une
victoire à la française comme disait des
inconnus liste l'histoire ne retient que
le résultat ne retient jamais l'avenir
et c'est vrai que bon après ça peut
choquer certaines personnes mais si
c'était la force vous en tant que coach
ou perrier appliquer cette stratégie a
tout à fait je vais tout à fait c'est
pourquoi j'ai déjà fait peut-être pas se
la jouer sur deux façons en tant
qu'entraîneur on joue sur nos forces sur
l'effort de 20 on va on va forcément
accès le jeu devint comme j'ai pas je
préfère les vieux mais béziers à
l'époque la grande époque de béziers où
ça joue et quand cocotte avec un ballon
porté
non mais voilà c'était un peu ça là
c'était sa force il fait rentrer deux
joueurs le règlement lui permet environ
la loi veut dire que bravo c'est c'est
pas beau c'est pas mais c'est efficace
à la fin du match c'est le gain du match
donc là dessus tactiquement et
absolument rien à dire et je joue sur
ses forces
on n'est pas là pour il est pas là en
tant qu'entraîneur pour faire plaisir
aux spectateurs et ga données nominales
également vouloir un petit peu également
ce plan il est pourtant canton mais
quand on met en effet ce que pour les
puristes quand même
un essai de deux ans c'est beau aussi
c'est faire un ballon porté ses
tactiques c'est pas ça mais ne faire que
ça prend le match si c'est sa force si
c'est sa force on peut pas lui en
vouloir
puisque leurs ailes résultats lui
donnent raison donc il va pas balancer
les ballons derrière un 6/6 ici là que
des mangas et si les mecs sont des gars
de vox qui chope à melun donc il nous
est très froid ce jour la russie
pourrait même cépage et pacifique pour
mettre un petit peu de francs pour tout
le monde mais pour les deux équipes mais
si les gens de derrière les casernes
humaine tu vas pas leurs filets les
ballons donc qu'il a joué sur ses forces
on peut pas lui reprocher ça alors on
peut pas lui reprocher je suis
tactiquement il a joué sur ce fonds se
relayent vous aussi vous chez un petit
peu aussi à windsor perdu lundi la
tactique c'est dans le basket à part
quand on est en danger
la technique la tactique c'est de jouer
sur nos forces et sur les faiblesses de
l'adversaire et d'obliger cet adversaire
à réagir par rapport à ce qu'on lui
propose c'est ce qu'on lui propose
pendant tout le match on lui propose
alors josé qui ne peut pas réagir on
appuyé on va jusqu'à la fin du match
comme ça et perd mais doit respecter
l'adversaire
oui tout ça ah oui totalement on lui
fait on lui montre justement une de ses
faiblesses qu'il devra travailler l'uci
veut progresser mais ça c'est dommage
que que que l'équipe adverse n'est pas
su réagir parce que s'il sera la 4 et
c'est comme ça en saison 4 et 7 6 4 et
c'est comme ça c'est dommage qu'il n'ait
pas trouvé la solution pour les contrer
sur ce genre de choses
il existe quand même quelques solutions
voilà donc bon tout ce qu'on peut
regretter mais on ne peut que dire bravo
est-ce qu'il faut être fataliste qu'on
ait de sky rugby en face non parce que
talisman il faut simplement alors
finalement on pouvait rien faire sur ce
match là il était plus fort que nous oui
ça va devenir sans alors à de le dire
maintenant il faut aussi réfléchir et se
dire on ne va pas cela on est sur la
face de match aller il ne faut pas qu'on
retombe dans le même piège au match
retour et donc il faut
savoir trouver trouver des solutions et
se servir des erreurs qu'ils ont pu
commettre pour ne pas les reproduire mon
fils à 7 ans découvre une nouvelle
discipline est il ce après chaque course
il se rend de fait les erreurs en
appétit il se rend compte des erreurs
qu'il a pu commettre et donc du coup il
ne les a reproduits pas la fois d'après
et je pense que voilà c'est ça qui fait
qu'on se construit qu'on se construit au
fur et à mesure donc là voilà c'est ça a
eu 2 e et peut-être au coach parce que
les joueurs je pense le compenser le
coton et je pense quand on est quand on
est sur le terrain
ben on réfléchit à un street avec ses
coachs de retrouver de trouver de par
leur coach justement la chevreuse doit
rééditer ce type de performance où il
doit le faire évoluer leur jeu dans le
futur pour espérer aller encore un peu
plus haut parce que là ils sont
actuellement deuxième du championnat et
ils vont deuxième de la poule deuxièmes
de leur union ils peuvent possiblement
de corps en course pour monter
est-ce que c'est un père a un peu plus
haut alors il est certain que lorsque
lorsque lorsqu'on est fort sur ce
secteur de jeu comme la devant mais
qu'on a que ça à proposer lorsqu'on
n'est pas complet comme équipe d qui va
tomber sur l'équipe qui va pouvoir les
contrer devant si derrière il n'a pas la
solution pour pouvoir écarter le ballon
et puis passer derrière
forcément ça va limiter ça va le limiter
dans l'évolution de son championnat et
face à des adversaires qui pourront
répondre à ses forces à nos positions
donc là effectivement forcément c'est un
peu limite limite limite comme cum cum
cum jeu comme il ya derrière
aujourd'hui on en parle donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya d'autres équipes qui vont
le savoir et donc qu'ils vont pouvoir
anticiper cette cette situation pour pas
que ça se peut pas être responsable en
tout cas la descente de chevaux classés
non mais céder egima plus complètes sur
les bus sortent c'est normal on range
maintenant les ballons ovales
pourparlers handball dans notre focus du
jour
nous allons maintenant prendre la
direction de plaisir pour parler de
sport un match d'entraînement entre les
moins de 18 ans du sky vgp les féminines
du paris 92 était organisée ce lundi 17
décembre dans un la palais des sports
bien garni avec 600 supporters le match
amical a finalement été remporté par les
jeunes yvelinois face aux professionnels
sur le score de 34 à 28
on écoute les réactions ils sont plus
grands plus costaud plus lourd plus
rapide plus vifs
ils sont 60 sur le vendeur on n'avait
aucune chance aux mondiaux le match mais
c'est un match de travail dont 71 raison
qu'on arrache ne plus jouer sur la
trajectoire de balle après on en pack
étonné qu'on a peu plus puissant serait
bien si l'on n'en fait un bon match de
la globalité et je trouve ça super
intéressant dans plein de domaines et le
souhait de l'entraîneur pourrait être
exaucé d'autres rencontres entre les
féminines du paris 92 et des jeunes
divine mois pourraient être programmées
dans le futur
la question sur ce thème est ce que
c'était un match pour du beurre oui ou
non
oui en sachant que ça pouvait peut-être
les faire progresser à un petit duel se
profile non je sais pas vous savez pas
trop être un dessin en additionnant vous
êtes indécis puisque je connais pas trop
l'historique de l'organisation de ce
match donc
donc c'est un match amical les moins de
18 ans du coup du pib gp rencontrer les
professionnels du paris 92 méfie du
paris 92 sont venus pendant la trêve du
coup la trêve handball avec l'euro qui
s'est profilé en france et par
conséquent sont venus avec moins de
joueurs sont venus avec tout simplement
une remplaçante d'accord match amical
non enfin un petit duel du coup non vous
étiez d'accord autour cet homme savage
pour du beurre en fait un petit duel
entre vos gens lisent et on peut pas
dire cf un jeu mais oui pour du beurre
parce qu'il n'ya pas de sélection il n'y
a pas de commandes il ya
de choses à gagner derrière deux niveaux
à conquérir
maintenant c'est il ya quand même de
quoi apprendre
elles viennent en sous-effectif elles
combattent
enfin ils combattent elle sait comment
dire elle joue contre des jeunes qui
sont normalement moins fort qu'elle mais
il ya quand même à apprendre en fait il
ya il ya toujours quand même à prendre
donc après pour du beurre je dirais pas
pas forcément viel dujarrier dans la
parole à gagner rien volé j'arrive oui
pour du beurre parce que
habituellement ce ne sont pas des
phrases c'est simplement une compétition
entre des femmes et des hommes le seul
sport qui fait que les hommes et les
femmes se rencontrent c'est l'équitation
et là ya pas de ya pas de différence
là on n'est pas de différence entre les
femmes et les hommes sur un cheval c'est
tout voilà ça sera par excusez moi sur
l'équitation est donc là voilà c'est
quelque chose pour prendre de
l'expérience je sais que les filles
aiment jouer contre des mecs parce que
ça va être des matchs le plus agressif
comme l'a dit la joueuse qui avait l'air
d'avoir un peu elle l'avait un peu
mauvaise alors le gros souci en fait du
match les filles du paris 92 sont
ressortis très faux ça parce qu'elle
était fatiguée tout simplement elle
n'avait qu'un remplaçant mais une
remplaçante et les garçons ils sont
allés à fond il ya beaucoup de
remplaçants et ils ont offert un petit
peu brusque on va dire dans leur défense
les règles les règles du match amical et
peut-être que les règles ont été remis
non on était mal fixée au départ c'est à
dire que veut pas non plus faire
n'importe quoi oui ce sont des joueuses
professionnelles mais en effet si elles
viennent avec une remplaçante
de l'autre côté on peut pas dire c'est
bon on a trois mecs à chaque poste et
puis tout le monde joue tout le monde
joue tout le monde joue à fond en effet
ces déséquilibres et je pense que sur ce
type de à l'avenir sur ce type de
rencontre il faut un petit peu comme au
foot d'hier on a le droit à trois
remplaçants ce qui n'est pas du tout le
cas world mais on a le droit à la même
chose pour une équipe comme pour l'autre
et à partir de là on jouera avec les
mêmes armes mais déjà cédé mais qui sont
tous très jeune puisque c'est l'équipe
de
18 ans césar - 18 ans -18 l'un 16 17 18
- de 8 face à face à des filles c'est
vrai que ça peut être ça peut être sympa
quand même
il peut y avoir quelque chose et une
vraie belle confrontation
la serre est aidée ou et ai été un peu
pipés et je peux comprendre que des
filles il avait un peu en travers de la
gorge genre oh moi j ai fait si oui ça
compte pour du beurre mais là on parle
effectivement la joueuse et elle a l'air
un petit peu frustré mais il faut voir
dans quel état d'esprit c'était fait
pour moi c'était vraiment un match
d'entraînement qui avait aucune
importance d'ailleurs on donne même pas
le score aussi le score et il n'a pas
être exactement 34 à 28 alors je les
donne est toute à leur bord je connais
pas fatale sur excusez moi mais bon
c'était vraiment un match d'entraînement
pour la frustation sportive en disant
philosophe finalement dans leur tête
c'était une compétition était là pour
gagner non c'est un match d'entraînement
je pense que les deux ont à prendre
chacun l'un de l'autre que ce soit les
joueuses professionnelles féminine où
les jeunes les jeunes de plaisir et
chacun à prendre et c'est le but de ce
genre de manifestation sportive séparer
de compétition on peut pas opposer
on peut pas on peut pas opposer en plus
le handball qui est un sport quand même
à ce physique faut le reconnaître
donc on peut pas on peut pas opposer les
deux c'était vraiment pour moi un match
de préparation d'exhibition des grippes
même pas l'exhibition de préparation moi
je sais que par exemple dans le rugby il
nous arrivait en tant qu équipe senior
de jouer contre des jeunes les équipes
jeunes du stade français ou des who du
racing parce qu'on sait que c'est des
jeunes qui qu'un bon niveau rugbystique
et qui vont aller très vite donc on
apprend de ces jeunes là on n'y va pas
pour gagner
on y va simplement pour apprendre et
plus pour perfectionner et certains
points qui nous font défaut
donc je pense c'est plus dans ce sens là
il fallait mettre complètement de côté
le côté que justement compétition quoi
je pense que la petite erreur qui a été
qui a été fait c'est ça c'est qu'ils les
jeunes auraient dû se dire on va
regarder comment elles sont organisées
comment elles sont placées sur le
terrain
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir prendre de
leur de leur jeu et et la forçant à
poser leur jeu va forcément poser leur
jeu
moi je je me souviens d'une
dans une compétition où de cyclisme sur
piste où j'ai vu un mec faire à quelque
chose que j'avais jamais vu avant et je
me suis toujours dit ce truc là si un
jour j'ai besoin de le reproduire
je vais l'utiliser alors j'étais
spectateur là mais je pense que dans ces
moments là voilà il faut mettre à part
le côté résultats comme comme le dit
jean faut mettre à part le côté
marquer marquer mais c'est vrai que
aider tout fin se servir de ce qu'on va
voir chez l'autre pour pouvoir ensuite
s'en guérir sa manière par un citoyen
contrairement à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure là pour le rugby contrairement
ce genre de rencontre c'est pas le
résultat qui compte c'est la manière
alors que total on disait le contraire
et là j'ai l'impression au cateau
l'interview on aurait dit qu'elle rami
qu'elle a perdu un match de championnat
donc elle est frustré on dirait que donc
comédien peut-être que la chose a été
présenté mais toute façon c'est pas une
question de présentation de c'est une
question de réaction aux subventions
versées surtout une préparation pourrait
voilà c'est une réaction de sportif mais
je pense que c'est aussi aux entraîneurs
de dire là le résultat jeunes en dessous
on gagne compères nous en dessous là on
est là pour travailler la manière
contrairement au championnat où le
résultat est impératif
et qu'importe la manière dont classe aa
pour moi elle était présente sur ce type
de rencontre on est là pour essayer des
choses et se dire ça ça marche ou ça ça
marche pas tout à fait voilà après c'est
positif pour les jeunes vignes amant qui
ont gagné face à des professionnels
oui mais bon ils ont aimé d'ailleurs ça
va leur apporter du tout même s'il avait
une médaille beau souvenir c'est bien
joli tout ça pour soi telle aurait moins
que tu dis qu'il ya une petite guerre
d'ego ou mine de rien les filles sont
quand même un peu dégoûté parce qu'elles
se disent merde j'aurais bien non ce
pardon j'aurais bien jours et bien
performé un peu plus et les jeunes sont
un peu en mode on est les meilleurs on
est les champions et on frétille et
voilà c'est vraiment les vaudois ils ont
quand même été de vent à plus de 600
personnes simples quand même leur
permettre à ces petits jeunes de gagner
en expérience
gagner en expérience non pas vraiment
parce qu'elle soit qu'ils ont joué
vraiment que sur
leurs mêmes schémas classiques habituels
donc non pas tellement gagner se sont
fait voir donc oui ça flatter leur ego
maintenant moi c'est plutôt notre équipe
que j'aimerais 92 grenade dont
j'aimerais parler s'ils sont venus avec
un seul remplaçant de l'as et qu' ils
ont pas pris ce match au sérieux et donc
lentement parce que beaucoup de joueuses
étaient partis à l'euro oui mais bon
quand c'est d'autres matchs y trouve le
moyen de les faire revenir
donc c'est que c'était pas vraiment un
match de préparation pour eux c'est
juste que c'était une obligation sauf
que les joueuses qui elle joue sur le
terrain veulent pas se faire marcher
dessus
et sachant pas ce que c'est normal que
ce soit en match amical sportivement que
c'est un match amical ou un match de
championnat on a envie que notre coach
nous met dans les bonnes conditions pour
qu'on puisse réaliser le match qu'on est
en train de réaliser pour notre coach et
notre staff est là je pense qu'il devait
y avoir une divergence d'opinion entre
l'organisation du match par le coach et
le staff et les joueuses qui sont
retrouvés là au milieu asie à bombannes
est ce que vraiment on est là pour
travailler
on est là pour faire plaisir au public
et aux matches qui est là et on sait on
est dans l'arène quoi rapidement ces
vagues comme tu dis ils ont certainement
pris ça un petit peu à la légère et on a
beau dire qu'il leur manquait des choses
parce qu'elle était partie parti pour
jouer pour jouer au hockey mais je pense
qu'un club de ce niveau là il doit avoir
une équipe réserve dans lequel on peut
aller choper des nanas et à qui on peut
aussi nous donner de l'expérience est
partie du top 5 du championnat de france
oui donc sa confiance sa confiance que
je dis ils doivent pas voilà ils ont ils
ont raison ils se sont ils se soient là
c'est pas possible dans le sac la charte
entre une deuxième fois il a dû jarrier
un je vous propose maintenant de parler
de basket le chesnay-versailles club de
r1 a vu arriver cet été bamba cei un
joueur de 39 ans qui a passé une
quinzaine d'années a joué dans les
salles de nationale une et de nationale
2 avec trappe puis vendre pour son
d'année des fils a décidé de venir à
versailles pour aider le club à remonter
on écoute les réactions ah c'est sûr que
ça change ça change la donne
c'est un joueur d'expérience qui apporte
qui apporte pas comme je vais me dire
l'expérience mais également
voilà il prend vie prend sous son aile
les plus jeunes et puis ça à soi un
petit peu le groupe en sérénité en tout
cas je suis quelqu'un d' équipe donc je
partage je je suis là pour l'équipe
voilà donc je suis pas là comme j'ai dit
je suis pas là pour marquer 40 points
amis ni jouer la star donc si je suis là
pour ça jouer jouer l'équipe et je me
suis bien adapté bombe a également
participé avec le sénégal à la coupe
d'afrique et aux jeux africains la
question sur ce thème
à 39 ans peut-il être un plus pour
versailles oui on pas de débat
aujourd'hui un collègue vous qu'il
connaissait très bien joué avec free
voilà elle prenait bien impressionné
tout le monde y ont joué ensemble cette
année mais je le connaissais déjà la
rampe ce qu'on a joué l'un contre
l'autre comme moi je jouais dans
d'autres villes de la france et
bien sûr c'est un gros péché
l'expérience dans ce domaine
quand on a des objectifs de montée
surtout d'original nationale il ya quand
même un petit fossé
avoir des joueurs d'expérience comme lui
oui comme sylvester
bon bah c'est vraiment un gros plus
hélène qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
certains vont plus également bah oui je
suis d'accord même à 39 ans oui parce
que de toute façon l'expérience est là
je veux dire oui mais voilà il
même si je veux dire en vieillissant il
ya des performances qu'on a moins moins
qu'avant on est quand même au niveau
technique au niveau tactique aussi bien
meilleur l'expérience et après c'est une
histoire des clips dans l'équipe
oui pour moi c'est un plus et puis
basket l'avantagé du basket aussi
support permettant quand c'est que c'est
un sport dans lequel il ya énormément de
changements et donc de temps de repos
possible à dire qu'on peut très bien le
faire jouer deux minutes le sortir cinq
minutes leur faire jouer trois minutes
enfin bref donc dans les temps forts
dont on aura besoin de son expérience de
tout son physique dans le money time
par exemple dans le money time en lui
fera rentrer mais on leur a reposé cinq
dix minutes avant donc l'âge ne va pas
jouer surtout bamba a gardé une
condition physique qui est qui est
supérieure à tous les autres jeunes de
l'équipe donc déjà y est vous qui vous
aussi qui est quarantenaire je vois je
crois oui oui et justement parce que 40
ans on peut être un sportif de haut
niveau comme de haut niveau parce que
bamba il est encore au niveau
maintenant il est complètement on m'a
jugé pourquoi reprendre l'exemple de
chris hoy qui est devenu champion
olympique du karina 36 36 39 c'est très
proche
aujourd'hui mois 42 j'ai encore des
performances qui me permettent de me
bagarrer avec des petits jeunes juniors
sens sans être ridicule et sans être
complètement largué voire même parfois
j'arrivais à rester devant donc là si il
a une hygiène de vie correcte si ils
s'entraînent correctement pas de
blessure parce que c'est vrai que c'est
des sports c'est des sports qui sont
traumatisants mais donc voilà le la
seule la sympathie de frat-mat et que ça
peut être justement la blessure et s'il
passe à côté des blessures restions
d'économistes comme tu veux comme tu le
disais juste avant il n'y a pas de
raison que qu'il note qu'il n'apporte
pas un plus et puis ce que je disais
pour le le club de foot de versailles
avec
il entend faire du temps je vais rien
kiki et ben là c'est l'aura d'un joueur
d'un joueur professionnel qui va
rayonner sur tout le reste de l'équipe
et on les autres ne vont plus dépouillé
de la même manière oui on a lui si
jamais il ya un coup dur il peut rentrer
et il va apporter quelque chose de plus
et puis bien sûr l'équipe adversaire
pure est il ya de l'autre côté il y à un
ancien pro il va avoir ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure l'anticipation il a
l'expérience
il va pouvoir anticiper des choses que
les autres ne verront pas voilà c'est de
toute façon un gros gros peu un gros
point positif pour pour le chesnay c'est
clair genre vous a pas entendu faire ça
ils font fort
le gardien de foot au basket il ya
beaucoup d'habitants aussi averti a
beaucoup d'habitants mais les petites
communes c'est connu c'est quoi mais non
mais tout a été dit autour de la table
et forcément le basket est un sport très
tactique très tactique
lorsqu'on a sur 1,5 sûr que c'est qu'au
basket
donc non ce qu'on a sur 25 un joueur de
cette trempe à lui tout seul il peut
faire la différence
donc forcément ça peut être qu'un plus
de ce sport là
il a très bien expliqué que du bonus
corneille c'est plus un scoreur ou un
passeur il a l'air d'être assez albicy
tarifs et les deux en fait c'est le
genre de joueur qui va plutôt jeu juste
alors que si l'action lui permet de
scorer sans forcer le jeu va scorer
si l'action lui donne comme solution une
passe à faire il trouvera la bonne passe
à faire donc c'est pour ça que ça
agréable de jouer avec un joueur comme
ça c'est que tout est grand tout fluide
et ça c'est super intéressant et vous le
voyez faire plusieurs saisons à
versailles au moins deux moments de
jesper après après on verra
mais l'objectif c'est vraiment des
vagues montée en nationale 3 stabiliser
cette équipe en nationale 3 et après de
laisser la place aux jeunes pour qu'ils
puissent reprendre nationaux parce qu'on
sait que c'est plus difficile de monter
en nationale 3 que de se maintenir en
nationale 3 non cela nous on va tirer
attirer les joueurs à côté de lui vers
l'eau vers le forcément après dernière
chose et là c'est sur l'entraînement où
est ben il va avoir aussi des conseils
que les coaches qui sont là
habituellement ne peut être pas en terme
d'expérience et est derrière sur la
suite on peut aussi se dire ma c'est
quelqu'un qui va rester pour faire du
coaching sur le sur le club et j'imagine
que c'est l'objectif est ce que vous
cherchez déjà sur le coaching des jeunes
arriver directement mais un projet
justement à moyen terme au minimum quoi
donc il est déjà sur le coaching des
jeunes des moins 17 morts dans le club
donc ça c'est devenu un vrai joyau g il
ya quelque chose de voilà c'est pourquoi
pas voir plus en disant un jour coach de
l'équipe première
moi c'est ça que
c'est une mêlée c'est le club de
versailles dans les mains d'un ancien
joueur de ce niveau là oui pourquoi
pour que versailles continuer à briller
justement genre on va passer notre page
coup de projecteur dans ce coup de
projecteur je vous propose de revivre
les plus grands moments qui ont marqué
l'année sportive 2010 8 dans les
yvelines un montage de à sandrine
fontaine
[Musique]
il y avait une super ambiance
l'année dernière nous avions gagné
contre brest ce match là était très
serré et nous avons une nouvelle fois
bien joué ici et peut-être l'année
prochaine encore à gaz
[Musique]
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif
du bras de fer de comptoir vos poignets
soit bien droit et beau soit en fait je
me dis l'épaule bien en face que vous
soyez dans l'axé médian de la table
[Musique]
c'est un département qui est juste à
côté de paris
barrier là et en même temps c'est la
forêt c'est la campagne baptisée à tout
pour pouvoir faire du vélo le vélo des
champions comme la bicyclette en famille
tranquillement et tes amis
[Musique]
très positive
tous les bus étaient atteints pour viser
les choses de se séparer les partenaires
les collaborateurs aussi de
l'intégration
[Musique]
on est très chanceux d'avoir eu cette
fois le quart avant doublé je suis
vraiment impatient de vivre pleinement
cette expérience de mon premier roland
garros c'est génial c'est top
carter ont forcément on s'y attendait
pas forcément mais mais c'est vraiment
un super cadeau on va essayer de se
concentrer à 100% pour en tirer le
meilleur
[Musique]
victoire un peu logique et papa de
surprise pour moi psychologiquement et
physiquement je pense qu'on est un peu
mieux que maurepas sur cette deuxième
partie de saison donc pas surpris disons
qu'on a bien préparé notre match et
depuis un moment et puis on les aurait
été super motivés ils voulaient
absolument la gagner
[Musique]
c'est une tradition c'est l'histoire de
saint quentin en yvelines l'histoire de
cette colline ce site
il était à l'abandon et à que vraiment
nous notre club qui utilise aussi de
lacaune d'elancourt et quand on pense
qu'on y est il va y avoir les jeux
olympiques je pense que on a mis une
petite pierre à l'édifice pour que les
jeux soient ici quoi
[Musique]
aux gens motivés à quelques jours du
départ du tour de france pour lancer
notre départ du championnat de france
est toujours une course spéciale donc je
suis content d'être ici pas
[Musique]
c'est génial
j'ai été proche de gagner cette année en
amérique et j'ai été ensuite à deux
coups de la victoire de francesco
molinari à what works
quand vous êtes si proche vous voulez
vraiment cette victoire
et c'est un sentiment incroyable de
l'avoir au genre du net
[Musique]
la recherche du paris saint germain
aujourd'hui c'est de recréer un lien
avec l'ensemble de ses activités
sportives aujourd'hui nous sommes est
allé sur le territoire parce qu'il ya
une histoire qui s'inscrit de cette
manière là donc on voulait c'est la
première fois que le toutes les
activités sportives du paris saint
germain ont par s'implanter sur un même
lieu
[Musique]
une semaine fantastique une grande
expérience pour tous les spectateurs
et puis voilà on fût-ce à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial
pour peu partout sans qu'ils aient mis
bas oui oui ça c'est c'est c'est la fin
d'une histoire
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on s'attend toujours une
finale on aime la gagne et quand on joue
c'est parce qu'on dit souvent une finale
ça se gagne
là on a vraiment fait notre maximum on a
été on a été le plus haut possible et
plutôt que malheureux on est vraiment
heureux de ce de ceux de ce résultat
en tout cas de sur la saison une belle
répétition d'organiser des coupes du
monde et championnats du monde chez nous
en france dans cette installation
la fédération va y faire aussi ses armes
en tant qu'organisateur
[Musique]
même âge est bon on peut faire encore
quelque chose mais tu ne faut pas se
laisser aller
les jours on vous assoyez labeouf
fauteuil et bien vous pouvez plus vous
êtes foutus
tai shan ouais je continue tous les
jours
[Musique]
et
au début je croyais que c'était un rêve
qui pensait pas après quand on était sur
le podium et qui est la marseillaise bas
ça commençait à se réaliser petit à
petit
c'est moi début c'était magique pour moi
[Musique]
et
malgré la défaite lundi c est parce qu
on a abordé ce match là pour par le
remporter
on n'a pas remporté ce match mais je
tiens à saluer le courage l'abnégation
et le coeur que que mes joueurs ont mis
sur ce match la question sur ce thème
quel est votre moment préféré cette
table waldir oralement championnats de
france de cyclisme sur route à
mantes-la-jolie d'accord pourquoi pas
parce que je suis cycliste
juste pour ça que je suis chauvin bad
ryder cup ainsi bien sûr que la ryder
cup c'est un élément qui qui qui qui
rayonne à travers le monde donc ça eu
lieu ici et on n'est pas sûr de pouvoir
le revoir un jour donc bien sûr que
c'est formidable
maintenant je défends pas je défends ma
patrie je défends mon je défends mon
sport et donc pour moi ce sera ça
restera écarté la france corneille pour
vous haidar club propose que c'est un
événement mondial et on l'a une fois
dans notre vie quoi oui donc pour vous
aujourd'hui ceux-ci rider bien que
monsieur g / 10 / 1 vérifie et il ya
trop de différences cela alors que ça
qu'est ce qui vous a plu dans cette
ryder cup juste ans
les joueurs les joueurs ouais le
monsieur qui est venue jouer messi na pa
tailleur voudrait tiger woods s'est
quand même c'est quand même un gars qui
est capable de faire 18 trous et après
deux parties jouent au golf
bon c'est pas grave c'est pas grave je
dis non et puis robert marchand aussi
bon ben moi j'ai sur six ans oui puis
son énergie là on n'est pas prêt de
l'enterrer lui un non sens est en l'air
mais son record à 106 ans mais quelques
semaines plus tard 107 ans c'est fou la
fête de l'énergie qu'il a sur sept ans
il a fait un tour en vélo en bien sûr
pour faire diversion
moi je reviendrai qu'une chose quand
même c'est que c'est vrai dans ce convoi
elle le cycle que là les yvelines sont
une terre de cyclisme et du golfe
également et de ce qu'ils mangent
surtout avec cette année l'open et la
ryder cup genre robert marchand on va on
ne peut que saluer on ne peut que saluer
l'exploit de ce monsieur
il force le respect force ne peut pas
dire autre chose et une patate comme ça
c'est magnifique c'est un exemple car là
ils pourront aussi exemple ont vu il
faut pas être sujet à part malgré tout
suivre son chemin mais non
c'est collectivement les cougars devant
team ont tenu eux qui ont réalisé une
superbe saison
alors pensez quoi vous en foutez
expliquez-vous mais simplement je vous
en ai rencontré le précédent découvrir
le nouveau nom mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui dans le par rapport à ce
que les yvelines représente et sont
quand même de présenter en tant
d'événements sur un sport mineur comme
le comme le baseball c'est que ça passe
c'est une anecdotique
malheureusement et sa verrière équipe de
france mais dans le royaume et dans un
sport mineur encore c'est toujours cette
sur le problème on pourrait avoir un
club régional enfin comme deux des îles
ligne qui remporterait la la coupe de
france en football c'est aurait un
rayonnement plus important que la
victoire de des cougars sur 1 sur 1 sur
un titre national
c'est c'est malheureusement là
l'impact d'un pacte qui n'est pas assez
fort sur ce sport genre là les coûts la
deuxième équipe de france mais on a même
le petit jeune anne kuhm ling la clé
chaque de 90m bling and the holding
david et il est champion du monde ne se
perçoit donc c'est même pas deuxième
chopin de chaque paire de phrases
échappe toit du monde le gamin est
malheureusement
pourtant c'est comme ça c'est pas nous
ont appris que de championnat les
imminent tout cas beaucoup de chaque
bureau si tu ne sais sur seine
département de très sportif mais on
passe maintenant notre dernière page la
rubrique des bas dans cette page débat
nous allons parler course à pied sidy
diallo a ni mon teint de 63 ans réalisés
en huit ans plus de 180 marathon sur
sept continents parmi ces marathons le
sportif en a réalisé 42 pieds nus depuis
septembre dernier la dette a réussi à
terminer 15 marathon sans chaussures en
14 semaines pour prouver les bienfaits
de la course à pied pieds nus il était
sur notre plateau car les gens mais voit
que les pieds nus dans un marathon un
homme blessé is a mal partout ils voient
que moi je n'ai rien du tout il voit
mais piégé rien du tout il se pose des
questions
et quand je vous dis maintenant à c'est
mon 14e en treize semaines
ah bon anoh la voilà c'est juste à fait
l'idée de faire ces casemates ont un 14e
semaine parue dans le monde c'est pour
que les gens puissent il faut qu'il voie
parce que c'est difficile à croire
on est tellement convaincu des vertus
protectrices de basket que ben c'est
pour ça que je le fais et je le fais
toujours avec le sourire et pendant la
course parce que je ne suis le faux pas
je vais pas inventer de douleur il y en
a pas pour que les gens se rendent
compte et ça marche
la question sur ce thème son mouvement
peut-il prendre
non non vous avez décidé de partir
d'aujourd'hui plus regardées avec
attention les propos de 6 à l'eau oui on
avait déjà vu il aurait pu faire un tour
de bateau avec éric bellion il serait
bien non mais c'est très bien les
pauvres performances celui-ci des
surhumains et ce garçon il est surhumain
réalisé des performances comme ça quand
on sait le le temps de récupération
qu'il faut après un marathon il avait
réalisé sept marathons sept jours une
fois je me rappelle je me souviens de ça
je me souviens on avait parlé ici c'est
surhumain c'est sur le mets est d'autant
plus bienvenu chez nous il ya 63 ans et
à soixante trois ans mais il ya de la
marge
quand même pas arrivé à robert marchand
qui à 106 ans oui mais non mais quand
même ces sommes mais médicalement je ne
sais pas il devrait réitérer devraient
ils n'auraient faire des expériences et
sur lui parce que moi moi tout tout tout
tout les potes que je connais qui font
du marathon vous disent la même chose il
faut un temps de récupération quand même
assez important pour pouvoir repartir
sur un autre marathon
là ce monsieur il il est impressionnant
il ya là prêts à faire des adeptes
pieds nus bon peut-être chez lui mais
ici avec est ce qu'ils vont faire après
mon but vendre les nike et tout ça ils
vont et google et non non c'est pas
possible
non mais mais moi on là c'est pareil on
peut on peut que que s'incliner devant
de telles performances sportives
c'est sur lui-même pour moi ce qui fait
c'est surhumain bravo oui je pense que
je pense qu'en format sûrement surtout
c'est de faire également pieds nus oui
mais je pense qu'en france on n'a pas
cette culture d'être et de faire les
choses pieds nus le sport pieds nus en
milieu naturel
mais même en milieu urbain c'est pas du
tout je mets des talons
non non non non mais oui et non on n'a
pas cette on n'a pas cette cette idée là
donc je pense que c'est un mouvement qui
qui peut pas prendre ou en tout cas qui
va peut-être réunir quelques petits
adeptes sur un petit événement un petit
point
voilà sur une petite course quelque
chose comme ça mais pas un vrai
mouvement une philosophie de course
comme l'huile c'est mon avis non il ya
quand même quelques coureurs quand même
qu'il est qui le soutiennent et qui le
qu'il arrive à convaincre finalement
dans sa course 2 de retirer leurs
chaussures et de courir avec lui du
coureur amateur des courants provisoire
amateurs à des coureurs amateurs et en
effet j'avais aussi entendu parler vous
savez des petites chaussures la très
fine qui il est déjà intégrée trop froid
voilà apparemment c'est vrai qu'il ya un
énorme
il ya un touché qui est différent il ya
il ya une mais voilà aujourd'hui au
quotidien on vit avec nos chaussures
certainement à mal il a il a
certainement raison mais mais c'est
tellement ancré dans les
dans l'esprit des gens et puis si si nos
amis romains ont décidé des spartiates à
une époque c'était aussi parce que parce
que ben il ya un petit peu de confort il
ya quand même un peu de confort avec
avec ses chaussures donc avec nos
chaussures donc sarah ça remonte à très
longtemps bien avant que nike et puma
didace ou révolte ou adidas reebok et
puis et puis faire du lobbying donc
donc voilà il ya il ya certainement des
choses qui me vont bien à lui
je suis pas sûr que ce soit bon pour
tout le monde corbel est ce qu'on pense
à la théorie à tient debout voix pour
répondre à la question que vous aviez
posé est ce que ça peut prendre donc on
a tous répondu non enfin j'ai répondu
non aussi parce que justement dans la
société dans laquelle qui diffuse on va
dire ces images dans la tête
les mouvements qui n'eut ça n'existe pas
fait c'est presque arriérés on va dire
donc il fait zéro degré moins 3°
personne va penser à marcher ou courir
pieds nus
après phil brown également quand il fait
beau dans le pays
je ne pense pas que que le mouvement
prendra maintenant c'est clair que comme
l'a dit c'est un s'insurge c'est faire
des marathons des gens faire au civil
souvent en peu de temps
je ne sais pas comment c'est possible et
les faire pieds nus c'est encore une
prouesse que je peux pas expliquer donc
pour vous non puisque déjà les sportifs
des marathoniens ne vont pas courir
pieds nus dans dix quinze vingt ans je
pense pas parce que faut avoir ses
capacités physiques à lui et je pense
que lui comme moi c'est un
extraterrestre qui en a qu'un il y en a
3 sur la planète donc les autres qui
n'ont pas cette capacité là le ferons
pas oui je pense qu'il ya aussi une
adaptation progressive on peut pas
passer deux ans chaussures à pieds nus
d'un coup
allez la pièce sur moi quand même un
poids mais bakou et puis encore une fois
on parle que d'eux en moi et en a même
en quelques mois même en six mois
arrivera pas faire un marathon pieds nus
donc je pense que déjà les muscles du
pied de la peau tout en fait doit doit
s'adapter
il faut faut éric bellion est une fille
nue avec bellion était sûrement pied du
seuil d'information a appris ce matin
c'est la fin de cette émission re se
retrouvent début janvier pour une
nouvelle émission un petit tour de table
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pendant
les vacances du sport du sport des jeux
pas reprendre un poste de coach aux
états unis donc je prépare mon départ
d'accord bompard fait vous souhaite de
bonnes fêtes en tout cas à ces genres
vous avez passé je vais faire à
commencer avec l'entraîneur de chevreuse
schefer le père noël alors mal géré le
gâteau ces femmes on peut revenir là
dessus moi je vais manger
je vous appelle et été remis aux
familles je vais même famille enfin dans
le sud ouest
un classique on va terminer par une
citation du pilote de course
ayrton senna je crois que l'on apprend
et que l'on progresse sans arrêt nous
sommes sans cesse mise à l'épreuve
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur tv 78 et très belles fêtes
de fin d'année
[Musique]
oui